today the map will show the marketing
genius behind Bud Light's new Ultra
awoke marketing campaign has come out to
explain her strategy she says that she
wants the brand to evolve and ditch its
quote unquote frat boy image which only
shows yet again that leftists don't
understand the institutions that they
run also Camille Harris comes to
Nashville not to visit the families of
the victims of the trans-terror shooter
instead you came for a photo op with the
so-called Tennessee three quote-unquote
and a jury in Texas votes to convict a
man who shot a BLM Pro protester in
self-defense but the governor of Texas
has already said that he plans to Pardon
him thankfully plus the new mayor of
Chicago makes the case against failing
grades and homework in school he's not
as wrong as you might think we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
people don't like to talk about death
don't like to think about it who does
but that's probably why almost
two-thirds of Americans don't have a
will the people people die unexpectedly
all the time it would be foolish to not
be prepared for that especially with
resources like epic will are available
to do the work for you if you die
without a will the state gives
everything in your name to your next
living relative if you're not married
that excludes your significant other
um is that what you want you know what
about your end of life medical decisions
is that something you want to burden
your family with who do you trust to
handle your financial obligations these
are some of the hardest questions we
face in life and epic will is here to
help you through every step of this
process without with epic will you can
get it done in as little as five minutes
for just 119 bucks all you need to do is
fill out their step-by-step form and
they'll help you create your last will
and testament your living will and
Health Care power of attorney don't put
it off any longer don't procrastinate
any more than you already have go to
epicwell.com Walsh to save 10 on Epic
Wheels complete will package that's
epicworld.com Welsh
as a company Bud Light has essentially
gone into hiding ever since their
partnership with Womanhood cosplayer
Dylan Mulvaney was first announced they
put out a brief statement meekly
defending their decision but other than
that they've basically been silent uh
Bud light's Twitter account hasn't
tweeted anything since the controversy
began as the beer brand faces increasing
backlash and calls for boycotts in
summary the rollout for this marketing
campaign has been you might say less
than seamless and now we know who we can
thank for This brilliant idea or who Bud
Light can thank anyway although the
company has had very little to defend
their Mulvaney endorsement deals since
the deal was made public we only need to
go back a few days before the
announcement to get a more in-depth
defense an explanation of it a couple of
weeks ago the vice president of Bud
Light a woman named Alyssa heinershine
appeared on on a obscure YouTube podcast
called make yourself at home and there
she went into great depth about her
experience being Bud light's first
female VP something she's very proud of
of and about Midway through the
conversation she begins to explain the
marketing shift that she is Engineering
in the company and this is an effort to
be more inclusive and more quote-unquote
representative here's a the piece of
that discussion that has since gone
viral listen
I'm a businesswoman I had a really clear
job to do when I took over Bud Light and
it was this brand is in Decline it's
been in Decline for a really long time
and if we do not attract young drinkers
to come and drink this brand there will
be no future for Bud Light so I had this
super clear mandate it's like we need to
evolve and Elevate this incredibly
iconic brand and my what I brought to
that was a belief in okay what is what
what does evolve and elevate mean it
means inclusivity it means Shifting the
tone it means having a campaign that's
truly inclusive and feels lighter and
brighter and different and appeals to
women and to men and representation is
it sort of the heart of evolution you've
got to see people who reflect you in the
work and we have this hangover I mean
Bud Light had been kind of a brand of
Friday kind of out of touch humor and it
was really important that we had another
approach
so we see we see right away from the
outset this woman has of course
completely misdiagnosed the problem yes
Bud Light sales and market share have
been declining over the years but she's
somehow determined that the waning
interest in the brand is due to its frat
boy image you know customers have
stopped drinking Bud Light Alyssa
decided because they're concerned about
its toxic masculinity and its
insufficient focus on diversity and
Equity so she imagines a scenario where
the once typical Bud Light Drinker you
know is at the liquor store scanning the
options at the store of all the
different beers uh almost reaches for
the Bud Light 30 pack but then pulls
back and says to himself never mind I'm
only buying beer from companies that
have displayed an outward commitment to
inclusivity and representation then she
imagines the consumer going up to the
cashier and asking where they keep their
trans affirming beverage options
but you know I can't say for sure that
that scenario has never played out
anywhere on Earth
but this is not exactly how it typically
works in the real world the truth is
that Bud Light is declining because the
product is terrible first of all and
people have other options you know it
tastes like carbonated tap water
flavored with notes of old hay shoveled
off the floor of somebody's barn and
that's why it's not selling as well
anymore you know before the explosion of
the The Craft Beer Market people drank
Anheuser-Busch products because they
were forced basically they're forced to
they're forced to choose between
um that brand of piss water or some
other brand of piss water most beer
drinkers didn't even know back in those
days back in the old Dark Ages what beer
was supposed to actually taste like they
didn't know until the proliferation of
craft beer and ipas and now consumers
can pay three or four dollars more for
real beer
the effect on Bud Light sales it's
similar to the effect on what the effect
on Outback Steakhouse would be if a
restaurant that actually knows how to
cook a steak moved in right next door
and only charged a couple of dollars
extra just a very bad situation
meanwhile compounding Bud light's
problems is that the fact that sales of
beer in general all types have dipped in
recent years as many younger people
unfortunately choose to smoke weed
instead so all told Bud Light is facing
many challenges and many Challengers and
increasingly it's losing that contest
that's the real problem but it's not the
problem that Alyssa heinershide wants to
solve for her the the only problem that
she'll ever recognize when it comes to
Bud Light or anything else
is insufficient wokeness and before we
analyze that any further I want to
continue watching one more minute of
this interview the clip we just watched
is the bit that went viral but if you go
to the YouTube channel and you look at
the actual um
interview that it continues on this part
of the conversation continues on for
another minute and you hear something
that I think is is kind of important uh
listen to this
long story short Super Bowl spot fast
forward
I cast an incredible female
choreographer who just brought
incredibly positive amazing energy to
the spot we cast Miles Teller and his
wife Kelly teller but it was really
crucial to me that if you see that spot
Kelly is
Kelly is the heartbeat of that spot
you're seeing this whole experience
through Kelly she's the beating heart
she I would sort of argue is sort of
what propels you through that experience
and and that was intentional
um and then we had another really fun
spot first spot out of the gate was the
first time ever we'd had a female
protagonist in this really cool she was
sort of cool as hell bobbin and weaving
through a bar but anyway listen I'm not
going to pretend that there isn't so
much more work to do from a business
results perspective and of course from a
representation perspective but I feel
like you
you have to put your money where your
mouth is when you're trying to evolve a
brand and elevate it and bring in new
consumers so that's been incredibly
important to me
so there she's explaining the thought
process behind Bud light's most recent
Super Bowl ad Campaign which did not
feature Dylan Mulvaney that commercial
the one she's referring to is the one
where the actor Miles Teller uh comes in
the room and and dances with his wife to
while she's listening to hold music
that's what the commercial is here's
here's like 10 seconds of the watch
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
okay now the interesting thing is that
if anyone had watched that ad when it
first aired and then complained that it
was woke
you know they would have been mocked for
it they would have been treated as a
paranoid conspiracy theorist if they had
claimed that the Bud Light Super Bowl ad
uh that that one where they're dancing
to hold music had a liberal bias if
anyone had said that uh after all just a
commercial with two people dancing in
their living rooms what's woke about
that and yet she proudly admits that she
chose that ad because it helps further
her agenda to feminize the company and
bring it into alignment with her
left-wing values
it was just done in that case in a
relatively subtle way and that's always
more clever when they make it a little
bit more subtle and that's going to be
more you know then you have the subtle
messaging which gets into people's minds
without them even realizing but also
they put themselves in a position where
if anyone who's slightly perceptive
notices what they're doing and says it
out loud everyone else could say what
are you talking about don't be
ridiculous There's No Agenda here
except there is they'll tell you
the Dylan Mulvaney sponsorship was on
the other hand far less subtle and now
they're paying the price for really just
a lack of subtlety except that from vice
president Alyssa's perspective they're
not paying a price at all because she
obviously is not really concerned with
Bud light's Health as a company or it's
sales or it's long-term prospects
she almost certainly doesn't even like
the product probably hasn't had a single
sip of it in her life you could work at
a liquor store for 30 years and never
once see someone who looks like Alyssa
heinershide or has a name like Alyssa
heiner should walk up to the calendar
with a six pack of Bud Light I'm not
sure if I've ever seen a woman drink Bud
Light ever in my entire life
she doesn't like the product she doesn't
like the company she doesn't like the
customer base
she has yet another liberal woman put
into a position of power within an
institution
despite not understanding the
fundamental point of that institution
and hating whatever she does understand
about it
yeah we've discussed in depth why these
companies go woke why almost every major
company goes well cars are already gone
woke long ago and all those points still
stand but here's another reason just as
pertinent
every institution in our country is
being taken over by people who hate the
institutions they're in charge of
this is true in the corporate world this
is true in government
this is especially true in the military
this is true in many of our churches
this is true even down to the level of
the family which is the most fundamental
societal institution where many families
are led by mothers and fathers who have
no interest in marriage or in parenting
they treat their children like pets or
fashion accessories hence the
proliferation of quote unquote trans
kids
so across the Spectrum you find
institutions
that aren't really uh collapsing you
know from any pressure from without so
much as imploding it's a controlled
demolition
an intentional Act of sabotage from
within
Bud Light is just one example certainly
not the most significant or important
it's a symptom of a of an underlying
thing and it's no surprise to see this
happening as the left seizes hold of the
culture hatred of societal institutions
has always been one of the essential
animating principles of the left
and self-hatred too
now as I've said before leftism is a
religion of self-loathing teaches boys
to hate their masculinity it teaches
girls to hate their femininity it
teaches white people to hate their race
it teaches Americans to hate their
country it teaches westerners to hate
their history and Heritage and so on
that's where you find the kind of
engineered self-loathing at its deepest
levels closer to the surface is Bud
Light and all other corporations managed
by Executives who hate the companies
they run and especially hate the
customers that they serve
and hopefully at least now that feeling
will be mutual
now let's get to our five headlines
you've seen the negative effects
inflation has had on the economy as a
whole such as increasing the cost of
food gas and housing printing money and
raising prices to fix the problem are
reducing the real value of wages and
salaries I know firsthand the importance
of protecting your hard-earned savings
from economic uncertainty inflation
that's why I trust Birch gold to help me
invest in Precious Metals for my
retirement gold can help diversify your
Investment Portfolio by providing a
hedge against Market volatility and
economic uncertainty the stock market
can be unstable the value of your
Investments can fluctuate significantly
from day to day or even within the same
day precious metals will always have
inherent value gold is a tangible and
finite resource uncontrolled by any
single government or financial
institution unlike paper currency the
government can't just print gold
whenever it's convenient Birch gold can
help you convert your existing Ira or
401K into a tax sheltered Ira in
physical precious metals text Walsh to
989898 to get a free info kit on gold
today with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews Birch gold is the company I
trust to protect my future and yours so
text Walsh to
989898 today
so we'll start here unfortunately this
story was just breaking as I went to
film so there isn't a lot of information
at this point but here's what we know uh
at this point from The Daily Mail it
says five people have died and at least
six others have been wounded including
at least one police officer in a
shooting outside the Old National Bank
in Louisville Kentucky it's believed the
death toll includes the shooter who
apparently did not steal from the bank
so that wasn't the motive behind the
shooting apparently in the area of the
300 block of East Main Street in
downtown in the downtown area of the
city located just hours from Nashville
where a gunman recently opened fire to
Christian school and killed six people
um
dispatchers heard on the police scanners
have uh just have heard have have
indicated that the shooting occurred on
the first floor of the building which
was in front of uh Louisville Slugger
Stadium
Metro Police have said that they
neutralized the gunman at the bank where
terrified workers tried to shelter
inside a vault authorities say there is
no longer a threat to the public but are
continuing to urge people to avoid the
area so uh
they're saying five five
people have died so 11 casualties
include wounded including a police
officer here's what the police had to
say uh just after the shooting at a
press conference launcher
they've received a report of shots fired
and a possible active shooter at 333
East Main Street at the Old National
Bank
shortly after officers arrived on scene
with Louisville Metro Fire and EMS where
they encountered active gunshots still
being fired inside the location at that
time
the shooter was confirmed to be dead on
the scene we do not know exactly the
circumstances of his death at this time
five people have been confirmed to have
been killed inside at least six were
transported to University of Louisville
Hospital including one officer with
various injuries we were unable to
confirm the status of those who have
been transported at this time I will
reiterate that this is an ongoing
investigation this information is
preliminary and it will be updated
shortly we ask that the public remain
Away From The Scene It will be an
ongoing scene that will take a long time
to investigate but there is no active
danger known to the public at this time
uh if anyone has any information related
to this incident we ask that you call
574 lmpd we will have an another update
press conference at 11 30 where we'll be
able to answer more questions and put
out more information as of now that is
so uh not much else is known about the
shooting so we have to wait for more
details I did just see this from the
latest from CNN and they're saying four
killed in mass shooting that's the
number that they have but they are also
saying that it was a former employee
so we've already been told that
um which
leads you to believe disgruntled
employee kind of situation although we
still
we still don't know
um
what we do know it seems at this point
is that uh
this is another example of the police
once again running towards the gunfire
uh this time one of them at least one
was was shot in the process went to the
hospital we don't know the status of any
of the people that are in the hospital
um
and that's another reason why we just we
can't forget about the people who wanted
to defund the police wanted to make cops
into the villains and pariahs in society
are still working on all of those on all
of those uh goals
um who exactly is running in
to
stop a mass shooting at a bank like who
who's going to do that in society
if anything we can get rid of the police
the police or completely demonize and
villainize them
you know to the point where nobody wants
to be a cop anymore
well who's who are we relying on in that
situation
I mean what what's what social worker is
going to run into that
so that's something we just cannot
forget about the people who called for
defunding the police actually went
forward with it in some cases
which is an absolutely suicidal policy
as we see yet again here
this is from Reuters U.S vice president
Camilla Harris flew to Nashville on
Friday in a show of support for
Tennessee State lawmakers expelled for
staging a rule-breaking demonstration
otherwise known as an Insurrection for
gun control on the state house floor
after a recent school shooting the
so-called Tennessee three as the media
has dubbed them and Camille Harris
decided that she was going to fly up and
she came here to Nashville to do a
little photo op with the uh with the
quote-unquote Tennessee three
also Biden has invited them to the White
House
and we'll talk more about that in a
second but here is Camille Harris in
Tennessee
um speaking out in her very eloquent way
it wasn't about the three
of these leaders it was about who they
were representing it's about whose
voices they were channeling
understand that and is that not what a
democracy allows
a democracy says you don't silence the
people you do not stifle the people you
don't turn off their microphones when
they are speaking about the welcome of
life and Liberty
that is not what the Democracy does
okay I don't know exactly what she said
I had to pull my earphone out just that
shrill voice I can't especially going
directly into my eardrum that way I
can't handle it uh but it did look like
she was speaking to um a cheering crowd
there she doesn't get that very often so
she's very excited about that
and there is the uh from what I could
discern the claim again about this is uh
what's silencing democracy
now this this is actually exactly how
democracy is supposed to work
because again uh according to according
to our state constitution legislators
have the authority and I would say
responsibility to expel
um Representatives
who engage in this kind of
disruptive behavior
which is exactly what you know and
that's and that is really underselling
what they did to call it merely
disruptive
is quite an understatement because what
they actually did was was lead a
screaming mob into the Capitol building
and then they pulled out bull horns on
the floor of the house
which is not something that you're
allowed to do
and if you do that
um you know you you have now made
yourself according to the state
constitution you have made yourself
eligible for expulsion
the only thing wrong with what happened
to the Tennessee three is that it was
only The Tennessee Two who got expelled
they all all three of them should have
been expelled
and it's only because of one by the way
it's only because of one Republican
lawmaker that the third one wasn't
kicked out as well Gloria Johnson
so if you don't have any complaints it's
that all three of them weren't kicked
out
but certainly the two that were kicked
out deserved it
and that's uh that is that's how our
system works
you know we have a state constitution
our lawmakers abided by it that's
exactly what's supposed to happen
but more to the point here uh it just
shows you how
evil these people are I mean Camilla
Harris Joe Biden the Democrats in
general
that
what was it a day after
a day after these uh
two ridiculous showboating phonies were
kicked out of Congress which was like
they had no interest to being lawmakers
in the first place
I mean we saw the speech from the one
guy I think it was Pearson last week and
doing his uh best Martin Luther King Jr
impersonation comparing himself to Jesus
Christ This is not somebody who wants to
be a lawmaker
he wants cameras he wants the cameras
focused on him
okay he wants to work on cable news
somewhere and he'll do that now okay
he'll have a if he has not already
signed a contract with MSNBC or CNN that
hasn't already happened it'll happen
within a week guaranteed
so he got exactly what he wanted out of
it really in many ways
nothing to complain about but a day
later Kamala Harris
on a plane showing up in Tennessee
to meet with these poor uh put upon
persecuted lawmakers ex-lawmakers now
and yet
it's been two weeks since um
a trans terrorist
you know massacred children at a
Christian School no visit from Camilla
Harris
no visit from Joe Biden
and and to add insult to injury Not only
was there no visit but then she came
here for something else
and she didn't stop and meet with the
families
she didn't even stop and you know
go to visit outside the school where
there are flowers and candle setups do
it didn't do anything like that
completely ignores the families of this
uh mass shooting and then comes here
anyway and is like right down the street
from them and makes no attempt to meet
them
and then Biden who also has not visited
and won't uh he doesn't invite the
families to the White House he also
doesn't invite the hero police officers
who ran in there
and uh took the trans terrorist out
didn't invite them to the White House
now none of this is shocking it's
exactly what you'd expect we know that
these people are evil
scum really
the only thing that's
notable about it is just how
how little they're doing to hide it
anymore they're not even trying to hide
it you know I think that maybe I'm naive
but I think of if something like this
had happened uh I don't know
let's say 13 years ago if it happened
during
Obama's first term
and you've had a similar thing happen at
a Christian School I think that they
would at least pretend to care
now the Democrats of 2010 wouldn't have
cared any more than they do in the year
2023 but they would have at least felt
like they had to do something to pretend
and maybe they would have sent somebody
from the administration to one of the
vigils or to a funeral or you know they
would have met with the police they
would have done something at least
putting on a front
and now at this point they're not
putting on a front they don't care
anymore they're they're they in fact
it's more than that they want us
so when when we notice
that they're treating these families
like dirt and they're acting like they
don't care that well they want us to
notice that
so they might if they heard everything
I'm saying right now they would say well
yeah exactly
yeah that's right smart guy yeah he's
like now now you're now you're catching
on that's exactly the point
we want you to know that you are dirt
that we don't care about you
and if you're a Christian family and uh
you know you send your kids to a
Christian School
or you work at a Christian School
you know and you're shot and killed your
your children shot killed they don't
they don't they want us to know that
they don't care
it's not like you know it's it's not
like these people are totally oblivious
I know that with Camilla Harris
sometimes it may seem like that and
you'd be forgiven for thinking that well
she's just an idiot and and she is
certainly I mean this is not a high IQ
person by any means uh probably not even
triple digit IQ but at the same time
these are politicians and so there was
definitely a conversation guaranteed
there was a conversation at the White
House when before Camilla Camilla Harris
went to uh to Nashville there was
absolutely a conversation
about the fact that well you know the
families of the the people murdered a
covenant are there
now are you going to visit with them if
you don't visit with them it's going to
look there was that conversation and the
decision was made no we're not going to
do it
you know let people know that yeah yeah
it sends a message we're glad it sends
that message
that's where we are now
all right daily wire uh has this report
Texas governor Greg Abbott signaled
Saturday that he was working to get
Daniel Perry a pardon after he was
convicted in a case involving
self-defense
Perry who shot and killed a man who was
carrying an AK-47 at a black lives
matter protest in 2020 was found guilty
of murder by a jury on Friday in Texas
the uh the jury found Perry not guilty
of the aggravated assault charge
Perry was not initially charged with any
crimes after the incident but in 2021
district attorney uh Jose Garza took
office and decided to prosecute Perry
Garza is one of many District Attorneys
whose campaign was backed by a
billionaire Democrat Mega Donner George
Soros that's a very important aspect of
this case just to emphasize
that when this first happened and for a
year afterwards there was no effort to
prosecute Daniel Perry
the police who looked into it obviously
they're going to investigate anytime
somebody's shot and killed there's going
to be an investigation they're going to
question the person people involved
obviously and they did all of that and
they arrived at the conclusion that
they're not going to prosecute it
because no crime was committed and then
the Soros Goblin D.A gets in there and
uh decides hey we're gonna we're gonna
Circle back and go after him
um
Abbott said in a statement quote Texas
has one of the strongest stand your
ground laws of self-defense that cannot
be nullified by a jury or a progressive
district attorney unlike the president
or some other states the Texas
Constitution limits the governor's
pardon authority to only act on a
recommendation by the Board of Pardons
and Parole and paroles Texas law does
allow the governor to request the Board
of Pardons and paroles to determine if a
person should be granted a pardon I have
made that request and instructed the
board to expedite its review I look
forward to approving the board's pardon
recommendation as soon as it hits my
desk additionally I've already
prioritized raining in Rogue District
Attorneys and the Texas legislature is
working on laws to achieve that goal
Absolution to go after the Rogue
District Attorneys comes after uh
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis sent law
enforcement officials to remove a woke
Soros prosecutor from from power in the
state the only time that a source
prosecutor has actually been removed uh
from Power by a governor
David fugit who's the the lead
investigative detective in the case
Senate 2021 affidavit that Garza acted
with criminal behavior in the case now
Garza again is the district attorney
being accused by a lead investigator of
acting with criminal behavior in this
case
um quote I had several conversations
with the District Attorney's office
regarding the presentation of
exculpatory evidence related to Daniel
Perry it became clear to me the District
Attorney's office did not want to
present evidence to the grand jury that
would that would be exculpatory uh to
Daniel Perry
on more than one occasion I was directed
by the Travis County Attorney's Office
to remove exculpatory information that I
intended to present to the grand jury
during my testimony
of my original 158 slide PowerPoint
presentation
the presentation was reduced to 56
slides with almost all of the
exculpatory evidence order removed
so that's 100 slides 100 bits of
evidence
that would potentially exculpate Daniel
Perry that the district attorney decided
to remove and hide
which indeed is uh is Criminal Behavior
and I hope that after Daniel Perry has
pardoned if the pardon goes through that
you know he goes after the district
attorney for malicious prosecution
because that's exactly what this was
this is uh I mean it starts with
terrible news that Daniel Perry who
absolutely acted in self-defense okay
he's in a car's car swarmed by a mob uh
somebody points an AK-47 at him I mean
you don't have to wait like obviously
you don't have to wait until a shot is
fired in your direction
[Music]
before you act because by that at that
point it is it's too late
so if that becomes the standard if the
standard for self-defense is that you
have to wait
someone's point a gun at you
you're being swarmed by a mob whatever
it is but you have to wait until they
fire the first shot
if that's the standard for self-defense
then that's just another way of saying
that self-defense is criminal that
you're not allowed to do it
because you're not going to get a chance
more than likely
especially if someone's putting an AK-47
at you
so that's the horrible news the good
news is that Abbott is looking to Pardon
and um
you know this is this continues a streak
of
you know impressive decisions and
behavior from elected Republicans maybe
not on the national level
but we just saw it just in Tennessee
last week Tennessee Republicans decided
no they had enough of this uh they were
not going to allow Democrats to use the
floor of the house as a staging ground
for a political demonstration because
that's not what it's supposed to be they
kick them out
and then just a couple days later Greg
Abbott responding to this conviction
hours later by saying I will pardon him
if we get the recommendation from the
board
I think that um
you know not to take credit away from
Republicans in Tennessee or Republicans
and the governor of Texas or you know
what we see what's what's happening down
in Florida that's a credit away from
them because they have to be the ones to
make these decisions
but they are also responding like their
response this is this is a reflection of
conservatives demanding this it's like
we don't want to see we've we've we've
heard a lot of talk for decades from you
people uh we're not interested in that
anymore we know that you can go on Fox
News and you can sit there and you can
say all the talking points that maybe
that you know might be enough for some
people but for most of us it's not we
need you to actually take action
and we're starting to see that from
Republicans at least in certain States
and that's good
but again the fact that he was convicted
in the first place
um
is uh
a very troubling sign to say the least
this is only a week or two weeks after
the D.A in Manhattan pressed charges
against a parking garage security guard
for shooting someone in self-defense
after being shot in the stomach so I
just said a second ago that well the
standard is that you have to wait for
someone to shoot at you before you're
allowed to respond with with lethal
Force
um actually in in Manhattan
they want to make the standard even
tougher than that because in that case
the security guard was actually shot in
the stomach and then he responded by
shooting the guy and they still pressed
charges
now we know that in that case they
dropped the charges
because of the intense backlash that the
D.A was getting and also I think because
you know he he has this case against
Trump that he's trying to prosecute and
he's a lot more concerned about that I
mean that's the only thing he really
cares about and so he didn't want to he
didn't want any scrutiny that would
jeopardize that
and that's what ultimately saved the
security guards
you know uh saved him in that case
but they wanted to prosecute him for
that in uh in Texas they want to put
this guy in prison for what is a
clear-cut case of self-defense
and we know that the goal is to
demoralize us as Citizens is to make us
hesitate to to defend ourselves
make us vulnerable
make us helpless
because you know
they know ultimately that um
yeah they want to take all the guns they
want to confiscate our guns they want to
they want to overturn the Second
Amendment essentially they'd let if they
could repeal the Second Amendment they
would and yeah they want to do that but
they know that they can't that they're
not they're not going to be able to do
that they're not going to be able to do
even half of what they want to do when
it comes to uh to gun control or even
close to half
because because gun rights that's like
the one area
where conservatives have
all have drawn a hard line
and they did that and that's been the
case for decades now
unwavering
you know unwilling to compromise at all
this is maybe the one area where that's
the way conservative conservatives in
the mainstream have have handled it
um
so they know that uh that they're just
they're not going to be able to do even
a fraction of what they want to do
so now they're thinking well can we do
an end run that's what it's going to be
we can't get rid of the Second Amendment
if we do an end run around it and one
way to do an end run around the Second
Amendment is to say well sure you could
have your you can have your gun you know
and you can have your right to
self-defense
however if you ever exercise that right
then we're going to destroy your life so
yeah you have that gun but just so you
know if you're ever in a position where
someone wants to harm you it's lose lose
because if you
don't do anything you'll be killed if
you do something you're gonna go to
prison ruin your life
that's the goal here if they can't take
the guns away they can in their minds
anyway neutralize the fact that people
have guns by making them too terrified
to use them when the situation calls for
it all right so this is a video being
passed around of the the new mayor of
Chicago Brandon Johnson I think this is
video it's just there's a little bit of
older video uh it's not it's from before
he was actually like but um
in the video he's he's a former teacher
so he's talking about his position
um against homework and failing grade so
he's he is opposed to homework he
doesn't think that kids should get
failing grades in school here he is
explaining that
it taught me though was
pushing like to eliminate sort of the
standardization of our Public Schools my
students sometimes would get frustrated
I didn't offer any test prep many of my
other colleagues were doing it at the
time I was pushing our Administration to
move away from that
to be quite Frank with you I didn't
issue a lot of homework for students
that was my own way of sort of rebelling
against the structure
um
I don't think I ever gave a kid an F
I just I don't I don't know how a
student sits in front of you and fails I
know some professors may find that you
know you know it's slightly troubling
yeah so this is uh is being shared
mainly from what I could see by by
people on the right on social media and
another example of crazy
you know now the crazy Lefty doesn't
want failing grades in school doesn't
want homework
um I actually agree the thing is I agree
with him partially on this but but for
wildly different reasons
so if you were to continue listening to
that well you can almost guarantee that
before or after that or both uh he's
going to make a case that uh that you
know there's inequity in the schools and
it's a lot of it is racial you know
always comes back down to race and so uh
that's part of the reason why I didn't
assign homework like it's gonna it's
gonna become a racial thing it's gonna
all uh fit into their Narrative of
systemic
oppression against so-called
marginalized people and all the rest of
it I don't agree with that part
um
but the first part I do you know for
example homework
um
I I think that there's a very good
argument to be made that schools really
shouldn't be assigning homework
um
because and it's one of those things
that it only you know you hear that and
instinctively especially if you're
conservative you react against it
because it sounds you know it's it's
it's not what we're used to
you know we're used to all of us went to
school we all got homework and so it
sounds like if you're saying well we
shouldn't give Hallmarks to kids that
this is all this is more coddling the
younger generation and we don't want to
make them work hard and again that might
be for people on the left when they make
this argument that might be what
motivates them but there is a good
argument to be made for getting rid of
homework uh kind of the absurdity of the
concept of homework and the good
argument is that
um
you're s you know if we're talking about
public school
you're sending your kids to this school
building for six to seven hours a day or
longer and they're there for five days a
week and you got them for nine you know
eight to nine months of the year
if not more
you should be able to do you should be
able to to educate them
and do all of your teaching within the
parameters within those parameters
that's a lot of time okay it's hundreds
and hundreds of hours that you have
available to you
and you should be able to so if you if
you find yourself as a teacher needing
to assign homework all that tells me is
that you're wasted there's a lot of time
being wasted in class
because it's actually not now if the
kids are at school for six or seven
hours a day and they're and they're
actually being taught for six to seven
hours a day and that time is being
utilized and they're being educated
then to have additional work to do at
home that is in fact too much
okay you don't want he's a kid like a
nine-year-old kid
shouldn't be working on schoolwork for
10 hours a day it's too much it's
overload
you gotta have kids you gotta give kids
some time and space to actually be kids
and play and all that
um
so either
it's work overload
but I don't think it's really that I
think it's that so much time is wasted
in school you're not properly utilizing
the time
I remember this one when I went to
school it always would you know of
course I was biased I didn't want to do
my homework and very often I just
wouldn't do it anyway which is why I got
terrible grades but
um
I I can remember noticing this even when
I was a kid that it would be very
interesting that we would uh you know
say we would go to Spanish class and
we'd sit there
and we'd spend three days watching a
movie
there's that movie uh Selena with
Jennifer Lopez that came out in the late
90s and we watched that in my Spanish
class in seventh grade like I think
three times in a year and so we'd sit
there and it but this is you know you
break it up in the 45 minute chunks it's
really like three days of classes taken
up by watching Jennifer Jennifer Lopez
movie
and then after watching the movie the
teacher would say okay well here's your
homework for today
well this is all work we could have been
doing now instead of watching the movie
so you're wasting all this time
another thing too is that when when kids
go home they should be home with their
parents they should be with their
families that is also important
so what the schools try to do I think
this is part of this is part of the
strategy it waste a lot of time in
school waste tons of I mean hours a day
if the kids are there for six hours a
day very often three and a half to four
hours is a total waste
busy work nonsense you know all this
kind of stuff
um
but they take up their time with busy
work during the day and then they send
them home and they're still claiming a
hold on those kids
the teachers are saying well here's all
the stuff we need you to do while you're
at home well how much time is there for
the kids to actually be with their
families and be at home
now the message to the school should be
that this is your time this is the time
we're giving you with our kids it's a
lot of time okay six hours in a day to
teach a a child the subjects they need
to learn that's a lot of time
and you should be able to make use of
that time when they come home they're
with us now
that's family time
and you don't get to claim ownership of
that time too
so Brandon Johnson actually right
almost right but for
the wrong reasons as usual
let's get to the comment sections
[Music]
let me tell you something the days when
skin care was just for women are over if
you're tired of dealing with puffy eye
bags dry skin and wrinkles and want to
look and feel your best every day it's
time to start taking your skin care
routine seriously by establishing a
consistent skin care routine you can
improve the health and appearance of
your skin in countless ways this is why
you need to check out our friends at
genucel skin care Mark Herman used to be
the director of my show back in the day
but I requested he'd be taken off my
show because his face disgusted me now
he's Candace's director but try to get
back in my good grades he's been using
genucel's Ultra retinol to try to make
his face less visibly upsetting to me
and he's almost there there are some
things on a face you can't fix but
genucel can do quite a bit genu sales
Ultra retinol is effective in treating
acne by unclogging pores reducing
inflammation and regulating the
production of oil you can also see uh
you can say goodbye to Fine Lines
wrinkles and even those annoying under
eye bags gen yourself we'll have you
look at 5 10 even 15 years younger just
in time for warmer weather best of all
General sell guarantees results in as
little as 12 hours or your money back
while Mark's face doesn't repulse me
anymore at least not as much what's done
is done if you really care about someone
you'll make sure you're not uh they're
not disgusting when you look at them so
don't be like Mark visit genucel.com
Walsh to save over 70 off their most
popular package which includes the ultra
retinol and dark spot treatment before
it's too late every order subscription
uh every uh subscription subscription
box includes a luxury gift box with two
free Springtime Essentials just in time
for warmer weather and free shipping so
go to genucel.com Walsh
before I get to these comments uh I need
to tell you about something it's the
tragic conclusion to a saga that has
unfolded over many months and um
I've been putting off it's actually
happened a few days ago I've been
putting off telling you
uh
and I don't know how else to say it
other than Johnny The Walrus is no more
he has passed away
he has gone to live in the big Arctic
ocean in the sky he has been destroyed
by my own hand I must say so here's what
happened as you know
if you've been following this very
important Story the most important most
important thing happening in the country
for months now really
um I finally succeeded in taking
possession of the giant life-sized
walrus that was rightfully mine I
brought it home in December and I think
it was and this giant stuff walrus sat
in our living room and sat there for a
couple of months because there was
nowhere else to put it and uh because
it's so big and my wife strenuously
objected to having a giant stuff walrus
right in our living room and um she said
you know crazy things like it's
embarrassing when we have guests over
takes up too much space you know the
joke isn't funny anymore like she kept
saying all these things and um and they
were all absurd arguments I thought but
finally I compromised and I said I said
I met her halfway and so I moved the
walrus to our son's bedroom
and it was really hard getting in there
I had to like roll this big thing down
the hallway I was knocking over picture
frames and tables and everything and
everything was falling apart and I got
it in the room because I was trying to
save Johnny's life I didn't trust my
wife around him anymore
and um and because she had repeatedly
threatened
harm against him and so I I moved him
because because of the threat of
domestic violence against my stuff
walrus but there were more problems
because now this huge walrus was taking
up my son's room and two of our boys
share a room and it was taken up the
room they couldn't access the their
closet because the The Walrus is in the
way and we couldn't put a dresser in
there because there's no room because of
the walrus and so then their stuff was
getting thrown all over the floor and uh
and she had a problem with that
and it just became
it it
you know it became a source we would my
wife and I would have a disagreement
about something unrelated to the walrus
and would always go back to the walrus
you know I would make a good point she
would say oh yeah well you're the one
who brought this walrus home and it just
became this thing Civil War was
threatening to break out of my family it
was tearing us apart at the seams Johnny
The Walrus who had only ever given us
love and affection okay and frankly a
lot of money in book royalties that
sweet innocent walrus had become a
burden on the family and I was left with
no choice so on Sunday I did what I had
to do I had I had to take I you know I
couldn't I couldn't get them out of the
house in one piece so I had to cut him
into pieces to dispose of them I had to
rip out the stuffing cut off his
flippers I was just about to cut off his
head
with scissors and then my three-year-old
daughter comes in and uh and you know
bursts into tears and she says what are
you doing I said well I have to cut
Johnny the walrus's head off sweetie and
my other daughter is there and she said
you didn't have to put it that way Dad
is a little bit harsh so I had to buy
off my daughter by buying her a
different but smaller stuffed animal so
she'd be okay now she's okay with that
and my my kids were all like harvesting
pieces of Johnny The Walrus you know my
son wanted his head one of my kids
wanted a flipper it was a very grim
scene and uh but it was what needed to
do and now he lays in Ruins
in my garage until trash day and that's
it that I tried okay I gave it I I
fought for this thing I fought as long
as I could
but sometimes a tactical Retreat is your
only option
it's not a loss
I mean it is
but uh this is what we're left with I
brought them out to the garbage and I
wept bitterly not outwardly not
outwardly but deep in my soul I wept and
I'm still weeping
uh Jessica harling says
the ADHD thing is why I beg my husband
to let me homeschool our oldest when he
was old enough for kindergarten I had
worked as a preschool teacher and after
school an after school caregiver for
years I was my son's preschool teacher
and I knew from my experience with other
kids at the public school would push
push us to get him diagnosed and drugged
I'd seen it so many times these little
normal kids mostly boys zombified by
drugs
thank God my husband disagreed now 16
years later we found a million reasons
why it's so important to homeschooler
kids ADHD was just one of many bullets
our family has dodged by homeschooling
our kids are smart articulate
well-adjusted and talented let kids play
limit screens teach them Rich important
and true things no need for drugs
yeah well it's you made the right
decision and that's um
exactly right and you know you're also
if if uh it is always interesting even
though we heard that ADHD die that the
ad ADHD diagnosis is is rising among all
demographics including among women it
still is more common
among men and especially more common
among among boys in school
um which was always an interesting fact
that never gave anyone pause the people
who believe in ADHD is an actual illness
they never really stopped to think like
well okay if this is simply a mental
disorder that you're born with or
something however it works uh why is it
that most of the time it's a you know a
boy in a school environment
who seems to be have come down with this
mental illness or just so happens he was
born with it however you think it
happens
well it's because in large part where we
are diagnosing Boyhood itself
these are just boys who are energetic
uh they you know they don't do well
sitting still and and doing busy work
for hours at a time boys are not as good
at memorization as girls are so the
school environment is tailored
for girls not for boys
and because the boys don't fit in we
drug them into submission to try to fit
that you know square peg into the round
hole
um Allison says I wasn't diagnosed with
ADHD until I was 17 taking medication
really helped me to ease my anxiety and
be able to function in school
it's a real mental illness
although it is being overly diagnosed
well and I and I hear this a lot Allison
this will just be representative of many
of the other comments that made the same
point from people saying well you say
ADHD isn't real but I took medicine for
it and I'm doing better now or
you know we gave medicine to our son and
now he's doing so much better in school
look the fact
that
you took a drug and it's helping with
your performance
that might be a good thing it might be a
bad you know however you would judge
that but the fact that the drug helped
you with your performance or helps you
feel better
that in and of itself doesn't prove that
there's a real underlying illness here
okay any more than you know if you are
um
if you play baseball and you decide to
take steroids that's going to help your
performance uh on you know when you're
playing baseball it's going to make you
better baseball player does that prove
that you had some sort of
disorder which made you an inferior
baseball is like being not as good at
baseball is that does that now become a
disorder the fact that you can cure that
Affliction with a drug does that make it
now a disorder no
just but it's performance enhancing
there are drugs that enhance your
performance there are drugs that are you
know that illicit or illicit that make
you feel better
make you feel good right there's drugs
that do that
um alcohol can do that
that doesn't in and of itself prove that
it's curing some kind of disorder
and that's really you know that's
actually what ADHD drugs are these are
these are like performance these are
kind of educational performance
enhancement drugs it's kind of the it's
the it's the academic equivalent of
giving steroids to someone playing
baseball or playing a sport
um and the fact that it works in that
way again does not at all prove
that uh
that there's an actual underlying
disorder here
uh and finally
Ed Brad says to be fair Matt it's the
intensity of the symptoms not just the
symptoms it's how extreme they are well
yeah I get it I get that's what they're
diagnosing right I think I acknowledge
that
that you look at the the symptoms of
ADHD and all of them whether it's for
kids or adults all of them are going to
be totally normal things these are just
you know the symptoms of ADHD in
children that's just you're describing a
child that's how children are the
symptoms of ADHD and adulthood
not able to focal Focus disorganized you
have mood swings
all that kind of stuff like everybody
goes through that everyone does
um
and everyone acknowledges that
which is why and I acknowledge this when
we were talking about on Friday
um the people who diagnosed the doctors
who diagnosed this stuff they'll say
that well it's not yeah everyone might
feel this way and everyone might have
these uh you know Tendencies and
character traits but if it's if it's to
a certain level if it's extreme well now
it becomes a disorder
but what you haven't done still is
explain who decides what qualifies as an
extreme level for these different
character traits personality traits
behaviors what what's extreme what does
that mean where is that line crossed who
judges that and why should we trust them
to judge it
and even if we could all agree
you know uh
a kid not being able to pay attention
that's normal
if there's like an extreme level of not
being able to pay attention if we could
agree if we could all agree where that
line is
that still doesn't prove that it's a
disorder all it does is prove that
that's how this kid is
maybe inconvenient it may be difficult
doesn't make it an illness though
on its own
let's talk about something I don't
usually talk about unless I'm reading
this copy which I do a lot in fact uh
hair not mine my hair is handsome and
Brilliant because I use Jeremy's razor
shampoo and conditioner I'm talking
about yours because if you're not also
using Jeremy's restorative tea tree and
argon oil blend to wash your Mane while
you're doing it wrong and you're asking
to be canceled and banned from the show
forever Jeremy's razors is more than a
razor company it's a Men's Grooming
brand that doesn't hate men imagine that
their shampoo and conditioner along with
their exfoliating charcoal body wash are
all made from high quality natural
ingredients right here in the USA
they're sulfate free and even though I
don't know what a paraben is I know that
they don't have that either most
importantly it's all woke free they
don't have any wokeness in the product I
know that so stop giving your money to
woke companies who hate you head over to
jeremy'srazors.com check out their
shampoo conditioner and body wash
bundles today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
foreign
daily cancellation we must officially
cancel San Francisco State universities
you probably recall on Friday we
discussed the chaos that ensued at the
school when a former NCAA swimmer Riley
Gaines came to speak there gains have
been described by some media Outlets as
a conservative speaker but as far as I'm
aware she's never announced her
political views publicly at least I
don't think she has she may she may be
conservative she may not be all we know
is that she recognizes that men are men
women are women and uh she doesn't think
men should compete against women in
women's sports if this is a right-wing
belief these days and I suppose by
default it is it's only because the left
has entirely succumbed to Madness I mean
now if you recognize that the sky is
blue and two plus two equals four you're
automatically a far-right conservative
which is a situation that as an actual
far-right conservative myself I guess
I'm okay with because if the left wants
to give us exclusive ownership over uh
the most common sense and fact-based
observations you can make then I'll take
it I suppose
anyway gain spoke at uh San Francisco
State University on Thursday it wasn't
until after her talk that all hell
really broke loose a mob of enraged
frothing at the mouth trans activists
assaulted gains chased her down the
hallway forced to force her to barricade
herself in a room for her own safety and
uh just to review again if we didn't see
this video on Friday but here's what
that looked it sounded like
[Applause]
[Music]
grab my entire human rights
[Applause]
we remember that scene um as we saw on
Friday the the mobs stayed outside the
room for a long period of time refusing
to let her leave at one point someone
suggested forcing her to pay cash for
the right to leave safely this is
otherwise known as kidnapping uh the
crime that crime kidnapping can be added
to the charges of assault harassment
intimidation or at least that crime
would be added to the charges if there
were any charges being filed if either
the University or local law enforcement
cared to hold a rabid horde of trans
activists accountable but they don't
instead the next day a woman named
Jamila Moore who's the vice president
for student affairs and enrollment
management at the school she sent out an
email uh which which makes the mob into
both the heroes and the victims of this
story of course here's what you said
quote dear SF State Community today San
Francisco State finds itself again at
the center of a national discussion
regarding freedom of speech and
expression let me Begin by saying
clearly the trans Community is welcome
and belongs at San Francisco State
University further our community
fiercely believes in unity connection
care and compassion and we value
different ideas even when they're not
our own SF state is regularly noted as
one of the most diverse campuses in the
United States this is what makes us
great and this is what makes us this is
what makes us Gators and this is what
makes us great diversity promotes
critical discussions new understandings
and enriches the academic experience but
we may also find ourselves exposed to
Diversion views and even views we we
find personally abhorrent these
encounters have sometimes led to Discord
anger confrontation and fear we must
meet this moment and Unite with a shared
value of learning
this is already a load of nonsense of
course diversity does not in and of
itself promote critical discussions or
new understandings and neither does it
enrich the academic experience unless of
course a swarm of leftist zombies
chasing a woman down the hallway like a
scene from 28 Days Later counts as
enrichment
which in Jamila Moore's case or in her
mind it certainly does it's also what
she means by discussion and
understanding
specifically she wants people like Riley
Gaines to come to the understanding that
her views are heretical and unwelcome
and her life has no value so long as she
remains in her state of apostasy
continuing with the email it says thank
you to our students who participated
peacefully in Thursday evening's event
it took tremendous bravery to stand in a
challenging space I'm proud of the
moments where we listened and asked
insightful questions I'm also proud of
the moments when our students
demonstrated the value of free speech
and the right to protest peacefully
yeah that's
chasing down the hallway screaming
that's not only protesting peacefully
but also demonstrating the value of free
speech
we're to come and assault you
and and try to rip you to shreds if you
say something we don't like because we
value free speech
sure
she continues these these issues do not
go away and these values are very much
at our core this feels difficult because
it is difficult as you reflect process
and begin to heal please remember that
there are people resources and services
available and ready to receive our Gator
Community including faculty staff
members coaches and mentors who are here
to support you campus resources are are
also available equity and Community
inclusion counseling and Psychological
Services the dean of students office the
well-being of the SF State Campus
Community remains our priority
now it's hard to know where to begin
um once again we see how the words our
violence crew doesn't believe that
actual violence is violence
or even that words are violence
depending on what the words are and who
they're being said to
you'd think that if any words could be
violence if words could ever qualify as
violence in and of themselves it would
be the words that are screamed at a
young woman by a slobbering throng of
lunatics as she tries to flee a free
afraid for her life
except in that case words aren't
violence an actual physical assault
isn't violence either
she also applauds the uh the the mob for
their bravery because apparently it
requires bravery to a cost and harass a
woman who you outnumber like ten to one
or I don't know sorry 100 to one maybe
and she offers counseling services to
those who need to heal not for Riley
Gaines of course who was barricaded in a
room while a gang of trans militants
stood outside negotiating for her
surrender and demanding literal Ransom
payments
the school isn't worried about her
trauma
instead they're concerned about the
trauma inflicted on the mob itself
which is ridiculous of course but it's
not far it's not as far from The Mark as
we might think because the people in
that crowd they do need intense
psychological counseling just not for
the reasons that Jamila Moore would say
you know these people they they they
love to talk about Nuance you know we
always hear about Nuance we need to have
nuanced conversations to understand the
nuanced situations and this very nuanced
world we live in they say
but there could not be as we see time
and time again and again here there
could not be a less nuanced worldview
than this than modern leftism which is
what you saw in that video that's what
it is
to them it's all very simple very black
and white both literally in figuratively
because if you're if you are the enemy
and Riley Gaines qualifies as the enemy
then everything you do is wrong
everything you say is wrong
and there is nothing anyone anyone could
ever do to you
uh or anything anyone anything anyone
could say to you that would be
unjustified or overboard in their mind
enemies do not deserve to speak
or to live in peace or to live at all
their well-being is not taken into
consideration
unless we're considering how to destroy
it that is
it really is as simple as that and San
Francisco State University could not be
clear about it in their response to this
incident this is how nearly every
University would view this situation by
the way
which is something to keep in mind
before enrolling in one of these places
or sending your kids there and it's also
why San Francisco State University is
today canceled that I'll do it for the
show today or for this part of the show
anyways we'll go over to the members
block and become a member today by using
Code wall should check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]